[Applause]
thank you to givewell an organization
that makes it easy to find excellent
charities to trust
givewell is matching donations from
first time donors dollar for dollar up
to 250 dollars click on my link below to
donate and be sure to use the fundraiser
code microcosmos at checkout to make
sure your donation gets matched
[Music]
we have been very excited for everyone
who has ordered their very own journey
to the micro cosmos microscope and
started their own explorations
and we love seeing the photos and videos
you've shared with us on twitter of all
of the rotifers and nematodes that
you've been finding already
back before these microscopes were
available to buy though my trusty
co-host hank took a demo out for a spin
and saw a lot of this floating around in
the water
and as any of us would do if we had an
expert in our contacts hank decided to
turn to our master of microscopes james
for help identifying these hairy lima
beans
and james replied with the following
warning
they are ostracods and they will eat
everything in your sample and poop all
the time until there is nothing left in
your sample but a bunch of ostracods
swimming in their poop
ostracods are a crustacean encompassing
tens of thousands of species and whose
bodies mostly range from around point
two to two millimeters in length
and thankfully their size makes them
large enough for james to filter out
using a simple t infuser
which is how he prevents these animals
from turning his samples into a toilet
but their size is not just a useful
feature for filtering
it's also a clue into a much more
fundamental question
about the trade-offs between sexual
reproduction and survival
to explain what that means we need to
establish two things
the first is that if you're looking at a
male ostracod
you're essentially looking at a crawling
shelled penis
do you remember how we said earlier that
ostracod usually range from around point
two to two millimeters in length
well
for male ostracods about a third of that
length is made up of penis
or rather two hemi penis
which make up what ostracod scientists
have called the large muscular sperm
pump
the two hemi-penies in the males
correspond to the two openings on the
female ostracod which hold several dozen
eggs ready for fertilization
and these eggs can have different
fathers so male ostracods compete with
each other in part by having their large
muscular sperm pump actually pump out
large sperm
and when i say large i don't just mean
large for such a tiny animal
ostracodes produce some of the largest
sperm in the animal kingdom
sometimes up to 10 millimeters in length
which is around
182 times longer than human sperm
the second thing that we need to
establish is that ostracods are
remarkably well preserved
their bodies are protected by two shells
connected at a hinge which shelters
their soft bodies and life and secures
their remains in death
there are ostracod fossils dating back
at least 450 million years
and in their many hundreds of millions
of years they have spread to so many
waters and have been so well preserved
that their fossils tell us stories of
how the world's climate has changed over
that long period and how this little
crustacean has adapted in response
but in addition to their geological
storytelling
ostracod fossils have a few other very
notable distinctions
one distinction is that the oldest
fossilized animal penis we have found
belongs to an ostracod
one that existed around 425 million
years ago
the species was named columbus on
eclecticus
which translates to astounding swimmer
with a large penis
another distinction is that the oldest
fossilized sperm belongs to yes
you guessed it
the ostracod the remains were found in
an australian bat cave where the
phosphorus from many years worth of bat
poop ensured that the soft insides of
the ostracod would remain frozen in time
scientists even found a female ostracod
whose remains held post-coital sperm
and these simple facts about the
ostracod may paint a somewhat absurd
image of ancient crustacean genitalia
but within that absurd image is also a
profound question
is it worth it
is it worth the exceptional amount of
space and energy that the male ostracod
devotes to reproduction
to ensuring that its sperm will
out-compete all others
the animal kingdom is full of examples
of this seemingly simple question
think of the peacock whose ornate train
is exquisitely crafted to attract the
comparatively drab peahen the ostracod's
equivalent is its size
the longer the male ostracod the more it
has invested in its reproductive needs
and in general male ostrocodes are
longer than their female counterparts
the accumulation of these kinds of
differences is called sexual dimorphism
the higher the degree of dimorphism the
more different the male and female of a
species are
some animals have high dimorphism and
some have low
and so on both ends the question remains
is it worth it
[Music]
on the one hand for species with high
sexual dimorphism the energy an
individual might spend ensuring it
stands out from other potential mates is
energy that goes towards a biological
legacy
one that hopefully aids the species
overall
but that's also energy that potentially
comes at the cost of other essential
elements of an animal's survival
or makes them vulnerable
leading eventually to their extinction
it can be difficult to untangle this
balance with animals we see today whose
present day survival at the very least
means their choices haven't led to
extinction yet
but consider the ostracod
this is a remarkably well preserved
animal with a long history of investment
in sexual reproduction
and over that long history many species
of ostracod have gone extinct there are
beginnings and ends documented in the
fossil record so in 2018 researchers
studied 93 extinct ostracod species that
lived in the mississippi area around 66
to 84 million years ago
they turned to the fossil record to
quantify the differences in size and
shape between male and female ostrocods
of each species as well as to measure
how long it took for each species to go
extinct
they found that when males were larger
than females meaning that they invested
more energy and sexual reproduction
those species tend to go extinct 10
times faster than species where the
males were smaller
we're talking about the ability to
survive as a species for 1.6 million
years versus 15.5 million years
so when it comes to the original
question is it worth it
this result seems like a resounding no
for the ostracod the compulsion to
invest in sexual reproduction at the
individual level
seems to come at a cost to the species
overall
but this is one very specific context
with one very specific animal and it's
one very specific sexual dimorphism
the story of survival and reproduction
is more than just any one animal and the
question of is it worth it has only
living answers told across past present
and future
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
we'd also like to thank givewell for
sponsoring this episode givewell makes
it easy to find excellent charities to
trust
they spend over 20 000 hours each year
doing intensive research on charities
and all of that research is available
for anyone to view on their website
givewell emphasizes donating to
charities that have evidence of
improving people's lives like the
against malaria foundation which
provides nets for people to sleep under
so they're not bitten by
malaria-carrying mosquitoes or you could
donate to their maximum impact fund
which directs donations to the charities
that givewell has determined to be the
most effective each quarter givewell is
here to give you the confidence that
your donations are being used
effectively and you have the option to
do a one-time donation or set up
recurring donations givewell is free to
use and does not take fees from those
donations and they are all tax
deductible in the us and right now
givewell is matching donations from all
first-time donors dollar for dollar up
to 250 dollars click on my link below to
donate and be sure to use the fundraiser
code microcosmos at checkout to make
sure your donation gets matched
the folks you're seeing on the screen
right now
they are people who have supported us on
patreon
patreon is a place you can go and give a
little bit of money to the things that
you really think should exist in the
world and all of these people really
think that journey to the microcosmos
should exist
and we agree with them and we're so
thankful to them if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]